oh I'm so sad angry now so upset Go Go
Power Rangers down no doubt but about
him Box Tops what's up what's up in
ducks but how are you still alive
it's going on I can't even handle yes
yes yes all part of the plan inks what
are you doing come on okay you'll get it
back
you'll get it back I have faith in you
oh no this place is amazing
Oh makes you leave me no choice
you denied my Scrabble oh well at least
Ken didn't win [ __ ] that guy God dig it
all right what's up ah [ __ ] hey I got
new ones coming and it's a grapple oh
yeah hey you like you like that's part
you like this oh I nailed the wall jump
- holy [ __ ] don't you dare grapple me if
anyone grapples me don't you dad what
what's your plan here I don't like where
this is going okay no for me you had me
you totally had me Oh grapple grapple
hello guys I'm losing grip out of my
controller and I don't have time to
adjust yes
how about a failure you see what's up
Ken you want to druk it in your butt
[ __ ] suck a dick all of you all of you
all of you oh [ __ ] mingzhu zarnitz
you made me do it again still alive yeah
hey Owen mimics jab you and me [ __ ] no
[ __ ] wait up wait up
seriously though come on wait I could no
balls off I could die
what's up hey minx wait I have a present
for you why don't you um this is gonna
create permanent veins on my face god
damn how I figure it's the game is that
intense
oh I'm sorry oh no minx died oh no it's
you and me whoever wins this wins
everything everything you win an Oscar
you win all the babes and the slaves yes
like that pig movie babe no [ __ ] oh nice
shot bro maybe next time you'll win
idiot oh oh no it's not give them a face
give my Oscar I'll win you have you have
you have you have a hosts advantage
that's why you won the warehouse I don't
know how many I can handle like
seriously I'm gonna break a finger some
[ __ ] is getting those iron Keith come on
[ __ ] don't you dare tell me about
focusing Yuri losing me find him for me
I'll get away this one's gonna be great
whoa what in the [ __ ] no no
this is awful this is like my worst
nightmare I'm so gonna [ __ ] this up so
bad every Ken could you like stop
[ __ ] tryharding your heart out that'd
be great party one baby gym you don't
even know where to go see oh my gosh
shut up exactly why did I go right I'm
doing Sudoku oh look at my speed
it's fast it's like I'm have lightning
in my pants wait what that's not fair
just cuz I hit a trap doesn't mean I
should die well what happened
oh whoa guys geez guys that's whoa so
weird keys left the game what what
happened I clicked what does the loser
do Felix I don't know tell tell me
you're gonna lose anyway
come on tell me tell me something then
I've been lying I'm not a racist like
some other people eating this game ken
died because I don't even care
that's a nice card makes just had a
seizure we all don't see carries the C
Chester yep
that's what I said sea creatures in our
paints these winds are amazing
oh come on can I have a present for you
shut up Ken boxes yeah that's gonna be
my new thing mister we yell at box
instead barrels glasses I bet so nose
dust that already Ken its copywriting
you guys are terrible of wool jumpers
shut up [ __ ] know me I know you I
know you and I went to bat
no you're the best and you know
nothing's ever don't want to keep my
Daniel to shut the [ __ ] up
dang it nice going Ken I can't do the
ego jumps at all yeah but your Apple
makes you wanna kill something it's like
how dare you [ __ ] you grabbed me I kill
your family I can't believe how badly I
suck at these we'll jump this is like
it's very bad you remember how bad I was
in the beginning you gotta wait for it
to slide up just in real life oh yeah oh
[ __ ] oh shut up all right it makes we
got to get ken come on okay that's
Carrick's motors
I hate oh you can't really cooperate in
this game it's kind of difficult oh [ __ ]
oh thanks oh thanks oh no miss oh [ __ ]
you hate you little [ __ ] go cry to your
mommy
suck in her kitty take it mr. booze
sting it didn't even kill you I didn't
even kill you don't even touch me that's
way can't touch me you guys are American
I don't know I'm not American
you're like well I can't do this so I'll
wait up for you don't worry about just
kidding noob links with anybody wasting
that round thing here we go
don't grapple me don't you grapple me
okay please guys look at it's a moment
come on you should go you're not playing
the game correctly grapple him yes
facepalm me into the spikes after I cry
would you like
I'm not okay with this what was the one
that you it was very difficult maybe if
someone grabbed if they were add their
red one this one I say that one don't ya
that's copyright your copyright ma'am
oh it's this man we flee this map like a
gazillion times box box box they don't
even do anything
you run I think I said I mean lots lots
see they do [ __ ] on me but not you
shut up that's a good box man I mean
press you could be a box any day son
take it [ __ ] that's what you get
I've been watching too much breaking dad
okay can she handle double jumps she can
[ __ ] you a minx I mean why don't you
grapple why don't you grapple grapple me
and then I grapple Harry okay
Capel a grapple grapple [ __ ] losing
grip out of my stick that sounds weird
it's not really my thumb stick jeez hold
your stick harder okay Wow no there are
kids watching no it's gonna win come on
we could go on forever leave me